the world is saying goodbye to its most
famous
secret agent sean connery he died on
saturday and he was 90 years old
tina krause looks back at his life and
career
bond james bond
the world knew him as double 07. in 1962
sean connery catapulted to movie
superstardom as the iconic british
secret agent who enjoyed his martini
shaken not stirred connery escaped death
in seven bond
films do you expect me to talk no
mr bond i expect you to die each one a
hit
i have a confession to make what
actually i'm a spy the scotsman was born
thomas sean connery to working class
parents in edinburgh in 1930.
he grew up doing odd jobs had a brief
stint in the royal navy
and as a bodybuilder before finding his
place on the stage
sarah look by 1958 he was opposite lana
turner in the melodrama another time
another place four years later cast as
the first
james bond dr no made connery a
heartthrob
and a household name i've caught
something really wild this time alfred
hitchcock liked him for the starring
role of a blackmailing widower in marnie
in the man who would be king connery got
play opposite one of his closest friends
michael caine and in 1988 oscar came
calling for his portrayal of a
hard-nosed irish-american cop in the
untouchables
here's how you get him he pulls a knife
you pull a gun
he sends one of yours to the hospital
you see him want a history
connery took home the best supporting
actor statue
people magazine declared him the sexiest
man alive in 1989 with a cover
describing the actor as
older balder and better that same year
he played indiana jones father opposite
harrison ford
queen elizabeth ii knighted the scot and
washington paid tribute to connery's
heritage as a kennedy center honoree
he's the one and only
sean connery the actor who embodied
james bond
the gentleman's secret agent tina krause
cbs news london a life
well-lived